hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to simulacra now simulacra
is the spiritual successor and/or sequel
to Sarah is missing the game about a
phone and a girl who is abducted by a
cult now I have a funny feeling that
this game is going to be awfully similar
to that yeah
and I'm certain that it's going to be a
lot of exploring a phone and seeing the
world through the eyes of the horrible
demon device in all of your pockets
okay oh hello hint
Toby's birthday well I don't know who
Toby is and I don't know why I care
about it well whoa okey-dokey
hi you Sarah
you simulacra okay I don't like to find
Anna I don't know who Anna is and I
don't know why I want to follow gang
I've done me it's stupid I don't wanna
well alright everybody that is the end
of simulacra because I was clearly
warned not to go find Ana and I am NOT
going to do that
alright fine whatever well that was a
that was a thing huh well anyway let's
go back oh please wait while we were
okay do not switch oh okay all right
okay all right well ain't this a handy
dandy piece of software saved indeed
they said you though and you're blocking
my calls now where on earth are you Greg
you're a little a little needy I need
you need you to back off a little bit
okay new message from Greg talk to him
I'm gonna go here whoa ah that's not
good okay I feel like I shouldn't be
peering into this person's personal life
but here I go hi hello hello myself and
me a V log talking about a visa love my
mind whatever comes no wrong answers
nobody's gonna see this so oh look who's
been pretty crazy lately and I just
needed an outlet of sorts right of sorts
this is supposed to be therapeutic
I don't know first vlog hopefully not
the last okay well it doesn't feel very
therapeutic but whatever you say Ana
i'ma try to see what Greg's up to Oh a
little nerve like Merve Merve hey you
still with your boyfriend
come on Merv asking people are talking
consider that the things you say might
come off as creepy creepy I'm just
speaking my MA nothing wrong with that
isn't company policy to get to know your
colleagues better as well that's not
okay
yeah but you need to tone it down way
down telling me to wear my bareback
dress because it looks hot is not
appropriate you're making a big deal out
of this I'm just being honest I can't
even tell you you're pretty I don't get
it
you're Bo oh boy chill whoa boy I'm
gonna be your giver for the gift swap
you're gonna love what I have in mind
for you Merv goddamn it Merv yeah you
Merv the perv alright mom hey and I have
these cookies they need to pass to you
mom some other time I told you I have
tiny shelters and played for food box
finish stuff donate it why aren't you
answering your phone mom I need some
space so you only wanted to see me when
you need something that's not true mom
then why are you avoiding me I am NOT
then let me come over on busy you're
always busy we're like strangers well I
just want you to be supportive of my
decision that's all supportive oh boy
you say as if I never do anything for
you who paid your rent to tell me it's
going to be good for you by the end of
woody able to show all has to see your
mother every once in a while find mom
next time I promise good Anna oh boy Wow
so is there anything important here
besides BA whoa oh that's not good sorry
I'm at work just want to drown
everything out for a bit it's just every
possible shitty thing that could happen
happened at the same time and it sucks
I know you're worried but I'm okay I'll
call you soon I promise okay all right
okay man this mother just looking at the
time codes just like one after another
after another oh boy there's some
fighting going on
I'll give you so much oh yeah yeah
that's the way to get love extortion
it's the perfect crime it's all right
boy mmm guys like peering into phones
like this I don't feel like I should be
looking at this it seems like bad all
right
hello hello well that's uncharacteristic
of mother there would be like paragraphs
of that okay whatever right Ashley
happened again long literally so I
confronted him about something and he
denied it true message corrupted select
the words in the correct order to
rebuild it I showed it to phone him I
showed his phone through him and oh wait
yeah well let's go back hang on let's go
back I gotta go back I gotta go back I
gotta go back so I took his phone and
showed it to him ah I did the thing I
did it I don't know the night it shows
to the no way you look through his phone
it's wrong and no don't do anybody what
I'm doing your sushi okay
Oh someone's doing some someone's
cheating on somebody someone little
[ __ ] okay all right Greg oh boy I got
my calls will you please oh boy
you are the one that went out of line
yeah I know exactly what you're talking
about Greg because I know what's going
on here
you went through my personal property
I'm not even mad just disappointed by I
know you what are you dad here so talk
to me I can plan everything I look cool
lady cool offers it's been a while oh my
god you can't ignore me forever oh boy
[ __ ] I get it
[ __ ] it but I get it get back to me when
you're ready I'm gonna give you a week
okay I want to give you space Greg Greg
is the most hilarious person I've ever
heard
[ __ ] it's so much I agree Greg I
absolutely agree yeah let's see a new
phone who is this who is this ooh you're
good at me Ana
Oh give me the silent treatment
disappear now you forget I exist
ana is currently unavailable well I
should probably not say that I'm not who
you think I am what are you rambling
about if there's some kind of trick to
stop me from reaching you you're better
than the Santa I don't think I am you
keep nagging me as the couple we need
more so let's talk let's see why do I
bother sounds like you and Ana got
issues yeah what was that flicker about
oh you're not Anna for real who is this
you're not in a new fling or anything
are you in case you were unaware we are
dating let's see see let's see yeah I
get it I don't know it's just kind of
good I don't know if I should say that
yeah I get it I get it yeah I get it so
you don't know Anna why are you holding
her phone then let's see the phone was
left on my doorstep
she left her phone for some Rando
stranger weird why would she do that
let's see uh I think she's in danger I
think she's in danger yeah that sounds
good huh
is she okay let's see Anna left a weird
video send me that video all right sure
now whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
hey buddy whoa wait how do I know what
oh wait hang on
this video send that one there you go
did I do bad I don't know it's a good
thing oh is this some kind of sick joke
it's just a noise if you did something
to him I swear to God look ah buddy
let's see it's gone looks like it
deleted itself that doesn't make any
sense but it's the truth and the truth
always prevails WTF man no oh okay all
right bye Greg okay well anyway why are
you not talking I can't make up what
you're saying
sure okay take it off silent mode or
something it's my call not going through
[ __ ] something came up
I'll try again later okay all right you
better answer okay all right Wow Greg
what could be more important than your
so-called girlfriend disappearing in
some screws
oh ah a dating app if it's a like swipe
okay alright why am i dating on this
phone why would this be something I mean
if I'm on a snoop as much as I can on
this phone I guess I have rather snoop
real hard then okay alright let's see oh
God
who are these people if you sit oh boy
hey cutie hey there
I got a romantic proposition what is it
if you sit on my face I will eat my way
to your heart that is just the best man
a real oh he's a writer always a writer
oh that was something that he wrote oh
we thought about that real hard Oh God
Fred how many lobster dinners would it
take to turn your bedroom into an
acrobats gym hey I'm talking to you here
is this what girls have to go through
each and every day on dating apps just
non-stop like torrents of [ __ ]
opening up with one-liners about sex is
that what it's about
cuz I'm sorry tell me Anna what are you
monday priorities movies yoga happy hour
oh no response oh you need some rescuing
sorry I was caught up with work I'm here
but actually pick none of the above
reading anything interested you pick up
mmm philosophy ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
meeting up wait Oh
starting out with a lie probably not
good agz Alex do good to be through it
works at tea love grade volunteering at
old folks homes adopting puppies and
saving little kids from burning
buildings ah that is too good to be true
who the heck is next Dave like your pick
on eat cookie dough some time together I
mean you want to go out some time
together you there Wow Dave that you
won't be disappointed
okay all right anyway okay goodbye
Edwin hey hey animal lover you have won
yeah cat love la blaw whoa ba ba ba ba
right ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba huh no
response there that's weird
hope your standards are lower than mine
that's not that's not off to a good
start there Edwin I'm sorry about that
oh you like to travel your name should
be wander woman come on not even a pity
laugh come on there we go got it nailed
it man I'm so good about this why is
there a restore tool on this phone in
the first place I that's what I don't
even know hey Taylor I'm gonna respond
to you for I'm not Ana right now this is
some weird roleplay thing cuz gosh god
damn it I'll be your nurse for tonight
baby yeah you can tell me to shut up all
night long does my nurse have a name
Oh Desiree mmm yeah I'm dead that sounds
desirable wait oh that's not good this
role-playing thing doesn't sound like
you at all oh sorry I couldn't resist I
know you couldn't be Anna can't fool me
no sir sorry are you really
Oh Anna and I don't know each other okay
that's weird
and you're having your phone because it
somehow landed on my doorstep and I'm
gone through it like a creepy weirdo
okay it's kind of creepy this guy knows
me real good
Oh like you wouldn't do the same come on
right that's cool as long as you return
the phone or you're gonna return it
right yeah if you know where she is or
if you know where she is the whole point
of spark is to meet the girl I haven't
reached that part yet then try it for
weeks
or was pretty sure my catcalling line
work don't you agree
wait wait what can't go okay anyway all
right let's see your jokes are terrible
yes harsh not for you anyways
you wouldn't get it no you know I don't
get it I'll let her be the judge okay
put a good name for me if she comes back
it's Taylor Barrera tell her I'll be
waiting all right whatever why will you
be waiting
check out my updates I don't think I
wanna do that that was boring can I
check out my reviews I don't think I
wanna ah yes hell yeah yeah oh okay
wiping yep yep yep
yeah purrs yup Rooney yep did it but Oh
try updating your profile you're here
too so don't judge okay I'm gonna edit
my profile and see my name is my name is
my name is squirrel my age is 69 hell
yeah
works at a boy rod an undergrad at
mom's house good one tagline bag line is
oh boy sorry alright
and even less than a rebound or a hookup
please look elsewhere I'm looking for
the real thing got ants in my pants
and I'm ready to dance haha that's just
a euphemism to suggest that I have
multiple forms of sti's just one of the
upfront and honest with you all I figure
that the truth is better than a harsh
reality on the other side of the bed oh
boy okay we're done
nailed it oh yeah love that love that
okay love that
wait personal growth
gaming art and crafts alright nailed it
no matches near you done okay alright
squirt out baby
I guess oh [ __ ] who are you who are you
say something nice okay uh hey alright
goodbye
Stephanie whoa another girl maybe did I
get my settings wrong let's see you
swipe right didn't you ha got him got
him yeah but it wasn't really looking
who I was swiping lol since we're here
tell me something what's it like spark
everyone here sucks really my sister
told me is pretty much 50% lame jokes
and 30% unsolicited dick pic aren't you
scared
let's see I have a friend follow you
kinda sucks the fun out of dating isn't
it
no kind of I guess gosh what am i doing
worrying so much I have this fear that
the person I'm talking to is not who
they say they are ah let's see it's a
possibility I'm not gonna go too into
too many details about what it would be
that would suck so much to find out how
do people do this
let's see you won't know till you tried
it no you think so I mean what is the
worst that could happen right you could
be kidnapped and then your phone could
be corrupted by demons famous last words
okay you're scaring me now I think I'll
just stick to speed-dating
all right good good luck to you All
Right see ya anyway mark you're a dick
that's not an eye you there let's see no
the phone is still with me oh Jesus
Oh God let's see hey cool name where did
you get it squirt
let's see I hated my previous name so I
changed it to squirt oh my god how about
it people are goddamned chatting with me
change it it can't be that bad what was
it before hey new haha I'm funny watch
me up too you know what you won't
believe me if I told you now I'm gonna
leave it at that all right what do I got
here huh let me go back into my what is
this chat audio sorry I'm at work just
know I know that one Oh what do we got
here oh [ __ ] oh debt alright
why was that a thing
there it didn't but whatever you say
okay all right me uh-huh
nice nice nice good great awesome love
it okay all right good bye
what else we got your camera
whoa-oh-oh-oh
that's no good there's no good at all
all right what's this who's this that's
you is that Greg Oh
Greg looks like a real charmer hi Greg
hi Greg hi Greg okay tea coffee food
face Greg hand looking weird weird Falls
oh here we go
Greg possessed by demons okay what do we
got uh image karuppa Ted select the
fragments in the correct order to
rebuild the image I don't know dropped
it in the first place Greg Greg kissy
coffee lookee smiley what do we got here
oh yo got it okay got that good that's
oh hey happy birthday to you okay party
selfie stairs food carb what at whoa
friend all right
fries other friend door Pam got it okay
all right then
who's taking this picture wait is it
friend taking the picture is it like two
pictures of a friend friend friend wall
glasses ice cream mochi or whatever no
macaroons dessert coffee dough okay
friend friend
Tobias cat cat cat bath towel and
restored
rampe got it nice working out nice hello
okay that's all I fixed them I guess all
right whatever
doodlee doodlee doodlee do what's in a
surfer oh no I got nothing about that
let's see girl loses her phone gotta be
more to the novel now why wouldn't antic
all her own phone by now did you check
her text messages let's see
not sure if Ana wants you to know about
her messages not that she wants me to
know about her messages oh where is your
certificate permission oh god damn this
guy reads me like a book tell me what's
on her phone and maybe you can figure
things out let's see Greg is looking for
her huh
Greg's your boyfriend let's see her
boyfriend huh got ya she never told me
that well yeah that's gonna happen more
reason to her right I got competition
anything else still working on it
I got no idea what's going on so I get
it it must be packed with juicy details
nothing much to go on for now mmm okay
bud time for the next level you're gonna
dig a little deeper is your email open
or what does she like on jabber buddy
I'm already on this privacy doesn't even
exist to me it's not even in my
vocabulary
all right Snoopy do your thing if you
don't want to find a table all right
okay all right I don't know why trust
you Taylor go to hell I guess all right
try me Oh God I'm trying to find a
missing person okay anyway see ya whoa
wait is this a prank yeah it's a prank
okay anyway my own livestream or
something I'm it yes why don't you
answer it
I'm trying serious okay uh-huh say
something okay I tried you've been
reported for negative attitude
what's all right well anyway I've been
reported so I guess that sucks for me
all right
why to fear are you like let's see
you're not speaking can you relax I only
hear I hear only noise ah we're wasting
time whoever you are I need you help
this is bad she's not answering her door
and she isn't at work right now and
always notifies when she isn't coming in
even when she's five minutes late uh
well she did lose her phone hmm
pretty sure she'll find a way to call
the office this time around not a word
it's not like her at all
this video you claim to see you sure
that's Ana let's see Ana the girl the
pretty girl with the thick eyebrows yep
only with me oh yeah I don't want to say
that see uh and it's a girl on wallpaper
right let's try to be the least creepy
about this and she didn't say anything
about where she is or what happened to
her let's see she said don't find me
yeah she said don't find me that's weird
what the hell I swear if you're making
this [ __ ] up damn it let's see does she
actually want to talk to you who are you
exactly
I'm gonna pretend like I don't know
let's see okay I realized how this all
looks I'm Greg summers and his boyfriend
we had a small disagreement now she's
not talking to me and now she's
kidnapped right sure whatever you say
Greg yeah whatever you say
all right anything in her phone that
indicates where she might be
her jabber she updates it all the time
can you take a peek at it see where she
went no let's see you want me to stalk
her no that's no good okay
something might happen to her all right
it's just a peek to her jabber and we
can practically track her just to see if
everything's all right all we need is
one face-to-face conversation with her
Oh how long has she stopped talking to
you
how long can I stop talking to you weeks
we had a disagreement mmm okay I'm just
being the good guy okay that's not a
good story tried to give her her space
she treats me like I don't exist well
maybe it's for the best hands getting on
my nerves
uh you think maybe she's moved on I kind
of saw her all her um dating profile
doubt it she wants to break it off she
could at least say it to my face let's
see she has spark installed on her phone
I'm sorry you had to find out this way
sorry you had to find out you're kidding
me
she's already moving on and she matched
with anyone yet let's see how is this
relevant this is not relevant to the
current conversation stay on topic frag
we had one fight this bastard got a name
[ __ ] Taylor he sounds so handsome
I don't know I will deal with it when I
find her I think jabber is our only
option just look through it and tell me
the last post she did can you check it
herself she blocked no that's not good I
can't see [ __ ]
yeah there's no way to circumvent being
blocked yeah be quick about it I'll be
I'll be the quick is just absolutely
okay talk is cheap share your
conversation share your moments I don't
wanna oh no I forgot about password said
I'm a reset it Oh Toby's birthday I
don't remember this one eight seven dumb
nah man I forgot what it was already one
eight six nine oh no one eh oh boy huh
oh boy I used to know this I used to
know this I I thought I did stuck at the
email need your help
what's her passcode let's see her
password is some dudes birthday probably
a dog probably not some dude probably
dog did she who is she somebody named
Toby Toby's a dog damn you scared me
Here I am thinking she's talking to
another dude it's her oh never mind then
cat she loves it more than anything I
can't remember its birthday though let's
see I need it to help you I'm working on
it okay
okay I think she took a picture of it oh
wait a minute wait a minute I'm on this
oh I'm already on this okay so the
birthday party I think that was one of
the ones that I fixed oh happy birthday
18 July 1807 got it I probably should
have remembered that from the very
beginning of this but I didn't because
I'm stupid
alright 1807 1807 ah why is my nose
running hang on I got Chipotle napkin
just for this occasion perfect okay all
right
ooh reset password reset that and I'm
gonna reset it to something like but Dix
or something along those lines
it's usually what I get what's your
pet's name it's Toby indeed what's your
mom's maiden name wait I I have
conversations with mother let's see
Lauren Hardy I'm gonna go with Hardy I
think Hardy might be the one oh come on
okay let's try Hardy got it nailed it
best was your favorite movie
oh titty sprinkles I don't know about
this one
well you gotta find it what's my
favorite movie uh okay Greg let's see
let's see do you know Ana's favorite
movie if we're back on speaking terms
what kind of boyfriend are you hey I
know the important things all right and
yeah I don't need you judging me right
now why do you want to know her favorite
movie let's see the last security
question for Jabbar oh so you sell
clothes hmm Oh unusual login Nintendo
her best friend Ashley might know
texture but do it as Anna she might
freak if she finds out a stranger is
using in his phone so let's keep this
under wraps let's see how
I can't lie about this kind of thing
they are both close if she knows you're
a complete stranger
she might not give you anything it's
easy just get what you need and no one
else needs to know what happened ah okay
all right I got a trick Ashley I don't
feel good about that hey a she flashy
boy that's that doesn't sound good I
don't think that's ever happened ever in
the history of ever in this guy okay all
right I'm gonna go all right hi Ashley
yeah no oh my god you won't believe what
I just saw
you can't tell anyone I told you I can't
guarantee I can't guarantee okay I know
you're sick of talking about Greg but I
saw Yolanda at my building holding a
Farris and Kane Footwear bag okay all
right this is good and juicy so I walked
up to her played it cool pretend to ask
for a card and stuff right turns out
that skank buy stuff for other people
I didn't realize a job like that even
existed sounds kind of lame don't you
think sucks the fun out of shopping like
what if you want to return something you
return it to them or they will return it
on your behalf shopping is pretty
straightforward why would anyone
complicate things also she looks fine I
don't think she's maybe she dealt with
it
okay I don't know what that's about
you're right I don't want to hear about
that okay let's go without and since
it's the only choice sorry last time I
promised okay
you wanted to say something
I'm feeling like girls night tonight
hells yeah
oh boy all right we'll get some oh boy
hang on wait no wait hang on wait I hope
this isn't time-sensitive hang on we'll
get some what do we eat together what do
we often eat right we don't eat anything
samosas okay they they eat a lot of ice
cream so I'm gonna go with that we'll
get some ice cream and put my favorite
movie on a dog's purpose again ice cream
does sound amazed although okay all
right a dog's purpose is your favorite
one but I can't tonight piles of to Do's
next time pinky promise speaking of dogs
I'm a shower now I smell like a wet one
okay goodbye all right I got it
a dog's poor fios hope I can smell
purpose correctly all right uh dogs verb
perfect easy I'm a spy practically I got
the gift of gab all right how do you
want to warn drugs as a bit of whatever
I don't care about this all right what's
going on here is there some like Easter
egg thing god memes Oh God wait is that
a picture oh that's a picture for manna
okay hang on and and oh boy man was
weird wait what whoa hey wait a minute
I didn't do that I didn't do that I
didn't I didn't do that what the hell I
didn't post that when is a get posted
and also wait a minute okay all right
well then oh all right
hang on wait there's something anything
that tells me more about Anna us tells
us what are you talking about what the
hell is happening here
let's see
see something weird just happened yeah
some weird just happened know what it
was you got through jabber mmm what do
you see
she literally just made a new post
awesome send it to me all right jabber
pictures okay
all right then it was this one I think I
think it was that one yeah that's her
place so she's at home then why isn't
she answering maybe she's still there
should have known I'm gonna go there
also what the hell is that knocking
sound who's weird let's see I'm gonna go
have a look it's gonna take a while so
stay put okay all right well oh hey hey
hey need your help
sorry you're jabber Poston looks like
you're home I want to check something
let's see shoot shoot ah okay Oh
remember I told you about my watch can
you check if it's at your place I can't
seem to find it let's see where did you
last but it check by the sink
oh I remember taking it off in the
bathroom and I'm gonna take some time to
look by guess vlogger who a new one okay
all right so we were on the phone for
hours and I only said like two words and
like a good bestie I sat through the
entire thing what it is about her in
guys she's always self-conscious about
like that with Greg should I be I mean
he's been good to me I guess
hmm that's confusing also what kind of
question is that I've no I'm not 100%
sure what you're trying to say there
okay
jabber knew jabber I don't know what
that is are you very careful business
under the desires all around security I
have no idea I don't know anything
really
okay that didn't work tell us all right
let me try to see can't find it I look
to spend a minute can't find it
no worriers just let me know if you see
it kay okay all right then
guess everything's good okay spark you
tell us it see interested in raiding or
arell okay goodbye and a block my card
so immature so I should get my guest
copy to work I need to register as a
guest but they need an authorization
codes it has to be done three Ana's
phone ah I see I understand
okay tech Titan conduct okay this is a
security company
you have to text people using okay this
feels this feels nice doesn't feel good
make sure to enter my full name well
what's your full name
wait what's your no eyes that's not
right hang on here no that's not right
either hand contact received from Greg
what's Greg's last day I don't remember
what Greg's last day but is what's
Greg's last day contacts here we go
crash Greg Sommers okay got it nailed it
got it okay got it
hello um hello Anna how can we help
invite guests invite Oh No invite guests
Greg Sommers this seems like a bad idea
but I'm doing it anyway
all right oh that looks fun
okey-dokey then I'll use that I guess
okay don't make me wait goodbye really
al but there we go
are you happy now you're in her place
and I don't know if that's a good thing
it works in the lift now can't believe
my card won't work anymore she gave me
this uh to me on our first anniversary
said I earned a frequent flyer card god
I hope she's home well I'm sorry about
that okay all right okay all right then
all right you tell us uh okay never mind
then okay see but something's wrong I'm
at her doorstep
something's wrong doors are already open
I can hear someone inside doesn't sound
like her I'm going in well good luck
take lock take lock in care okay there
was this voice for a sound [ __ ] I'm
recording this okay TV cats gone 200
OOP anything that stands out I guess
place is a mess there's stuff all over
the floor she's really fussy about
keeping things organized a robbery the
laptop is still here nothing else is
missing let's see what did you hear I
have no idea what I just heard listen
for yourself
Oh like this
yeah kind of creepy yeah kind of creepy
okay kind of creepy her laptop is still
warm
it's jabbered she definitely poses
something rip here then where the hell
is she her notebook is here too I want
to take a look all of this just doesn't
feel right something weird is going on
yeah no joke damn it
all right it's ghost daffodil there's a
reasonable explanation for this and it's
obviously ghosts yeah well tough luck
nothing is reasonable so far wait all
right maybe this is John something
happen Oh tell are you are you trying to
delete Ana's phone Oh me bleed what I'm
not doing anything
Oh did you do something will you dare
delete anything we need as much info I'm
on a clock here time factory reset oh
the hell calm the [ __ ] I am calm you're
the one panicking here tell me what's
happening
you said data is reset or something how
did that happen
let's see it's from Ana's laptop just go
there okay let me check her laptop oh
[ __ ]
let's see I see it too oh good job you
sent emoji it's let's see how the [ __ ]
that Apple I didn't touch anything let's
see uh start talking and start helping
okay okay don't remember how this works
go come on let's see tell me what you
see boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I see it oh
[ __ ] me oh tonight Oh No
Oh Oh her cat's name her company's name
for iris oh boy ah okay
alright uh Toby that's not right Toby
her comedy his name
Oh No huh-uh
Tobuscus oh boy toe butt hole nope
Tobuscus robustus Oh Oh too late
uh well I'm John bucket book I'm Bob
owned
okay well boned
[Music]
I don't think that was how how in the
world would you be able to do that I
didn't write down boy it's not like I
wrote down everything that's just
impossible
well [ __ ] this fan wants to warp squirt
this baton belongs to squirt the whole
sorry squirt
free Fulton sorry squirt
Fraenkel been that way in of squirm
cream pulp then sorry I misspelled it
Fraenkel thing
hello warframe tendon okay let's get
started
how old am i 69
where's your arm country region the
mound the Mon I'm on the Mon new user Oh
I'm very experienced
I want to manually configure everything
I would like to backup often like to
sleep later early I like to sleep early
favorite kind of smell punch and that's
not its spell pungent see what part of
the animal do you prefer to eat Oh
give me the sweet ass tell me about your
saddest moment in life I am a living I'm
a living rain cloud of despair all right
there you go
if everyone can only tell the truth all
the time do you think this will make it
worth a world a better place or a worse
place better do you swear to tell the
truth no would you rather know the date
of your death of the cause of your death
I'd rather know the date would you
rather lose all your mind or all your
limbs Oh
each I don't want to lose my mind
I guess I'll go limbs if you look right
behind you would you rather see a
floating disembodied head or a headless
body whelp
I guess I'll take the headless body can
you touch your hair like sure can
yep I can yeparooni so you agree to
surrender all your personal dated IRA oh
boy
of your experience and others would
decline but if we know more about the
user we can help them find it don't you
agree decline too bad Fran - then that's
not good thank you your phone oh thank
you Looney Tunes up okay alright welcome
hi squirt three Fulton alright okay
always watching over you oh this is
lovely
okay hi squirm
welcome to chats one year free yearly
subscription fee I hope to get squirt 49
[Music]
all righty then real happy about that
let's set this one okay open nope not
gonna do that no I'm just gonna go to my
phone contacts in their recent called
9-1-1 please hello this is an automated
police emergency response your call is
important to us
sorry all of our operators are currently
busy your call is important alright
anyway that didn't help anybody okay
I'll open it
on fire wow you are you safe are safe
you hmm I don't like this
thank you all nur I'm fine everything's
fine unlikely for long
it's boredom oh do not you need you need
to tune it up like this at all like it
oh let's see
woah you're the only one speaking era
apparently fancy yeah well here its own
okay hold nur do not believe it I like
the way you type all creepy-like
it's good Lukas resistors words okay all
right I see resist why what what's
happening it's image it's a wine see you
must have seen
okay all right this is something's wrong
are you not in nah no I'm not oh wait
sorry you are not in oh okay all right
well you nailed it on the head there
that's definitely not me this is not
Anna no now and aha
see she will be gone soon I don't know
why you're talking like a ghost that's
it how do I find her it depends on it
you will find her and find me
I didn't work out at all let's see ah
find her and you will find me nope god
damn
okay how about that find me and you will
find her nor you das Frick who will find
her okay got it nailed it I'm the best
all right okay if not oh look at that I
really don't want to look at this I'd
really rather not look at this to be
perfectly honest
[ __ ] I did that wrong how about you you
you and you got it now
that doesn't make any sound I don't even
know what that is that's just a normal
picture of a skyline on thing is what's
it seems nothing oh nothing nothing is
what it seems alright huh well I really
[ __ ] it up didn't I didn't seem good
okay alright if the data's gone I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you
alright everything is fine in now thank
God Oh God
you [ __ ] scared me I thought we're
gonna lose our progress I don't know
don't worry I fixed it so wink Winkle
Winkle liar you're just as panicked as
me this is too much weirdness for one
day okay here it is I found something on
her laptop Horne stash that's usually
what you'd find there is a time and
place for everything this is not unlike
you I could actually found something
useful there are some phone data backed
up one here another one at her
workstation that means her stuff might
you know I don't like that we work with
what we have I'm restoring it from her
laptop firt let's see I'm not so sure
something bad has happened well yeah I
mean obviously I can feel it so don't
you back out now okay Greg alright whoa
whoa easy there
so okay
Oh oh nice got it nailed it okay should
be done now I guess did you get it no I
got it Jesus Christmas I don't wanna go
through all that well else is there new
wait a minute
wait what was that picture that I just
saw wait a minute I thought I saw a
pregnancy test
there is no it's a picture of a
pregnancy test hang on wait a second
here yeah something's funkalicious huh
what is that Paris and cane extension
404 woods should I be writing some of
this stuff down because I'm not Oh
Farrah sim cane extension oh four oh
five Yolanda okay that was someone that
Ashley was talking about but I'm not
sure what that is okay weird no there's
gonna be a [ __ ] isn't it you you there
we go inconclusive have to try again
tomorrow
who whose picture is that why is it a
picture of someone's phone oh wait a
minute that's that's a picture of Greg's
phone weird
okay bloggers all right what do we got
here from the university to the school
of veterinary science we ought to inform
you that you have not been shortlisted
blah blah blah we thank you blah blah
blah they didn't even say why and they
have to take three months for this okay
all right sorry well you don't get to be
a vet I'm very sorry about that
yeah I guess okay any new history nope
okay all right new mail I guess study
leave Faraday safety that's the name of
the
company but oh well I'm not gonna
relearn and it's gonna fail again
rainforest god there's so many other
pieces of information how would he be
able to remember any of it
Oh Hannah looks like you were most
receiver for the next week's company oh
god Merve Merve I don't want to oh wow
tell me your body size and I will pick
the perfect grass for you I don't like
that that is terrible
make sure to give me your bust waist and
hip measurements oh boy oh that's that's
the worst thing that's the worst thing
ever that is literally the worst thing
okay alright dice roll when your life is
worth money okay oh boy is the
kidnapping for ran all right leave
chance to I don't you know that's that's
not good either man none of that's good
boy okay all right then what else we got
Taylor recovered I don't even want to
know about that Titanic what it's my
icebreaker haha funny no what is this
don't be I've got my eyes on you you're
everything that I see I want your hot
love and emotion and this D I can get
over you you left your mark on me I want
your hot love and emotion and this we
[Music]
okay all right well okay all right you
sing okay all right well then bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla tell us I'm
not gonna talk to you I don't even care
about that I don't even know if I want
to look at these okay what's this cat's
birthday yesterday well you did remember
you knew Greg you knew the birthday when
is your birthday
ah that's what that picture was who the
hell is Malanda who they'll is Jolanda
okay alright then you look through my
phone I knew something was up
oh boy I made a mistake I can explain
she was the client I need for the last
month's target she meant a few times
she's persistent okay it's unreal I told
you I'm not allowed to just get rid of
clients that doesn't mean you're not
allowed to [ __ ] clients okay I don't
know why you needed to send that in a
voice message but okay she was the last
close I need I know it's hard to believe
okay
alright that's not a disagreement Greg I
don't know how to break this to you
softly Greg but that ain't that's
alright anyway alright boy do you Anna
take two buys the cat as your lawfully
wedded husband to have and to hold from
this day forward for better for worse
for richer for poorer in sickness and in
health until death do us part
yeah yes I do I don't think you want to
marry a cat all right anyway back of
rocks back of bricks made of the poop
they dry out okay all right all right
okay all right wow that's a lot of
there's a lot of a lot of poop
references there but I guess all right
poop poop is the word of the day
apparently okay
hey um god I just read my text I am so
so sorry
can you do me a favor and just ignore
all of it how do we bit too much to
drink last night and I have no idea what
I was saying I'll make it up to you okay
I'm going back to sleep so I'll catch
you soon all right
okay all right weird but okay all right
I think that's all there is to check up
on so there wouldn't be anything else
okay Greg all right I am well informed
uh this is so wrong yeah that's how I
feel harder percent through and through
we got this far we just need to keep
pushing all right Greg I trust you
there's something else I was looking
through a notebook is it the porn
strache did you find the porn stash is
there something you were not telling me
let's see what are you implying sir it
says in her notebook that she met
someone on spark didn't you mention that
she matched with some people on spark
yes I did
yeah it's Taylor I told you that so
you've been talking to this guy all the
time how much have you told him let's
see
I was very selective you better not be
lying
did you anyone ever taught you not to
trust everything people say especially
it's from online for the basic common
sense
let's see you're a stranger till and he
sings so beautifully I am her feeting
bar friend so you better stop listening
to his crap and do as I say stay on the
line I'm gonna make some calls get to
the bottom of the spark thing okay all
right anyway I'm going to spark hey it's
wrong to share personal info that was
why was there mmm today's gonna be an
interesting day I can feel it
haven't seen you for a while where you
been yeah where you been it's not like
to miss you to mr. Jim I am film I am
fine
just got caught up with work that's all
going to take a short break don't worry
about me what you know front a stranger
anything just put some okay I guess
she's all right let's see I wish that
was true I wish it upon the stars you
know maybe you're overthinking it maybe
she just want to be left alone don't do
that Wow no wonder you're single fine
I'll work on my puns a bit more so what
happened exactly the Greg checkered
house or something
about the post let's see well wait what
wait wait how do you wait do you know
wait did you
who's smacking their lips over there
don't do that don't do none of that
don't do that he did but no sign of her
and I would have called her phone by now
she's okay okay and somehow she makes a
post exactly the same time as when Greg
is checking in on her doesn't sound a
bit strange Occam's razor
akhom let's see the simplest answer is
most often correct yeah they're all the
same thing right so let's say
hypothetically there's a possibility
that Greg somehow did something bad to
Ana and he's hiding it from you and oh
just a random thought what if Ana is
deliberately trying to get away from
Greg maybe he bombarded her with calls
and messages to the point where she just
went screw it and chucked the phone away
[Music]
I don't know about that let Greg know
the phone is okay alright I don't know
okay alright whoa oh whoops that's not
what I wanted okay I don't know why you
had to send it audio message about that
let's see go think about it what kind of
person in Greg is let's see
he's kind of a dick and is a pretty
sweet gal why would she date someone
like him being verbally abusive is not
far from being physical well okay all
right hang on a second here Taylor
excuse you all right is there something
else that I can I guess I have to just
talk to this guy all right whatever
let's see imagine he got blocked from
her apartment if they are indeed
lovebirds at most he won't have the keys
but by getting blocked as a strong word
maybe she is keeping him away the phone
Santa was almost deleted when he checked
her laptop this is troubling he's trying
to obstruct justice I think he's hiding
something big in the phone otherwise why
would he delete the phone's data let's
see I don't think he did it I don't
think it was him said every guilty
person ever all I'm saying is I think
there's a more to Graig than he's
leaning on again hypothetical what else
he told you he told me you actually met
Anna if I met her our job would be done
and I wouldn't be talking to you right
now
don't you believe me not even a little
bit no I do not well you're not making
this easy it's way easier to prove that
you met someone then you haven't met
someone you can trust me scouts honor I
think we need to before we move on you
need to confront him call him out let's
see I got a new batch of phone stuff to
look at all right did I like a great
he's hiding something I can feel it if
he did something to Anna we need to know
what it is remember to get your facts
straight and ask him about his actions
and behavior maybe you'll slip up and
tell you something we don't know okay
all right then all right get to the
bottom of the spark thing let's see Greg
I need to ask you something what let's
see
Oh I can't see what's at the bottom I
don't know no let's talk about Anna's
place what about Anna's place
let's see did you activate the phone
reset I told you I didn't do anything
are you calling me a liar if I wanted
the phone erased why the hell do i back
up the phone for you
let's see because you screwed up the
only one screwing around is you why the
sudden interest in me this is not the
time to be pointing fingers ah here I am
busting my balls to find her and you are
accusing me let's see what are you
hiding I hope you're done wasting my
time let's see let's talk about your
attitude come on let's talk about that
what about my attitude huh what about my
tune I don't have time to deal with your
feelings right now let's see you are
verbally abusive mmm
sometimes you come off as rude I am
really stressed out over here okay I'm
not sugarcoating anything for you just
deal with it
let's see you didn't header did you hey
hi hey do farm man I'm sorry I did not
lay my hand on her I would never
physically arm Anna ever what about
emotionally what about emotionally maybe
she's running from you let's look at the
facts huh
she didn't show up for work and she's
not at home is she hiding their job and
family as well she is missing Sarah is
missing not running okay all right sorry
about your relationship with Anna so
you're a shrink now yeah what's there to
talk about us see why did she block you
from her apartment we had a fight okay
how would I know she would block me I
just need to check if she is at home
let's see sounds like trouble it's still
Breaking and Entering Hey Hey
you helped at the very least you are in
a
accomplice what's with all these
accusations make your point
let's see you're not being completely
honest with me you are a random person
who somehow got Ana's phone I'm not
telling you any more [ __ ] you have
nothing on me so if you want to start
pointing fingers make sure you have
proof why are you so defensive looking
for Ana I believe this is her number yes
this is detective Marilla from the
Police Department received a report from
one of your neighbors
she mentioned that there was a
suspicious-looking guy entering and
exiting your residence can you confirm
if this is true call us if you wish to
report a burglary thank you and good day
mm okay all right well I don't think see
the thing is I don't actually think that
greg has like he's he's obviously messed
up but there's this clear scapegoat he's
just worried about Ana and trying to get
back to her even though he [ __ ] up
like he definitely [ __ ] up by [ __ ]
Yolanda but uh yeah there's more to this
than than meets the eye
definitely what if I didn't but if I
just went on living a lie
and he can do it looking me dead in the
eyes God and he hasn't stopped texting
any sense what what does that mean does
he still love me then why would he you
know what I hope it's positive
I hope she's pregnant yeah he always
wanted a family no everyone's happy hmm
okay everyone seems real happy new
everyone's real happy okay what's that's
not a random thought what is Greg killed
Ana
well maybe kill is a strong word but
what if he hurt her or something and
tried to cover it up and all you hear
from him is a lie huh nah Taylor you're
getting a little now you're overreaching
let's see I'm not even gonna talk to you
about that you're overreaching a little
bit here all right well anyway I got
nothing on him why do I need to tell you
this I'd all right are there and I left
him because he cheated all right okay
haha caught red-handed this or red
fingered because it's in text okay that
sounded weird now that I typed it out it
was the unlucky girl
Yolanda why do you why am i telling all
these details I got nothing else to do
god exotic name you know that sounds
like a motive to me
messy breakup fight things got violent
who knows I think you should call her
and ask if she knows anything about Greg
like a second opinion
get it straight from the source let's
see it's too scandalous for my taste I'm
gonna do it anyway but all right I think
it's time to give him what he deserves
remember we are here for Ana this is
necessary I might find you a lot of why
am i okay all right well I'll find
ulanda then
Yolanda hey yo yeah Yolanda not here
wait extension Oh 405 wait wait wait
wait my brain is connecting something
here wait hang on I've almost got
something yet okay hang on extension Oh
405 Ferris and Kane okay
all right hang on wait okay and this
look up Ferris and Kane
oh let's the ferris and Kate here hey
hey okay hang on I can do this I could
yes
[Music]
okay again welcome to Ferris and Kane
your personal shopper directory press 1
to request for a shopper press 2 to ask
about being a patron press 3 to find out
more about our latest promo if you wish
to return to the main menu at any time
please press 0 thank you to help us
select a personal shopper for you please
indicate what you would like to purchase
press 1 for robes and clothes if you
know the extension number of your
favorite shopper please press the four
digit extension number I know that what
if you thank you your personal shopper
assigned to you is Yolanda Yolanda you
two are increasing demand we can only
take a limited amount of clients at a
time after this call please wait for us
to text you at our latest convenience
thank you for picking Ferris and Kane
have a nice day Yolanda
yoyoyo Yolanda hey Yolanda let's see I
would like to know your best selections
what kind of things something casual
something stunning I'm gonna go with a
stunning please I would like that very
much
might I recommend do our best selection
of dress shoes boots loafers leathers
I'm not looking for shoes what are you
looking for that perhaps you keyed in
the wrong extension don't worry as it
happens at all the time I want to talk
to you about
the [ __ ] was that was anything was that
was that in the game was that in the
game I legitimately thought someone was
but it wouldn't have happened because
chica would have barked she could get
over
I'm so stupid was that in the gamer was
that oh what can I do for you officer
let's see Ana has gone missing huh
but I don't even know her something is
not right who is this did Greg put you
up to this oh you know it's illegal to
impersonate a cop right yeah he did that
Greg he's such a wily fella damn piece
of trash what did he do now let's see so
we both agree on something wink wink
wink wink so he ruined your life too
what else is new look if you're looking
for dirt on Greg I'm not getting
involved with him again let's see he
just broke into Ana's apartment whoa
hold up
time out are you telling this right
let's see it's true 100% oh I see it now
if you're implying that he actually did
something Nana I highly doubt it he
didn't even have the balls to break up
with me face to face he's too
[ __ ] to even be a criminal let's
see so you two dated huh
more like side girl booty call see he
cheated oh yeah I am all in for some
casual fun but having a girlfriend all
this time that's a low blow when she
find out about me all hell broke
and I ended up being the other girl okay
let's see did he get violent mmm god no
he's not the hitting kind when it comes
down to making a choice of course he
went for Anna and I get the half-assed
voicemail brick up okay that's
interesting that adds the new death hey
Yolanda got your text
so you know now that the scare is over I
think we should stop seeing each other
like immediately it's not just that it's
it's been fun but I haven't been
completely honest with you
I have a girlfriend and I want to make
things work with her yeah we agreed to
keep it casual right I hope you're not
mad or anything
yeah no our feelings this [ __ ] sucks
all right well that's stupid let's see I
Sam and a new light it is true 100% I
hope it's a piss colored [ __ ] stain
light at the end of the day he still
cares about her if only he knows how to
show it now everyone thinks I'm a bad
person I don't see he fooled all of us
if I knew he had a girlfriend I would
have stopped in Italy stupid babe I hope
that was helpful
it sure was I got to get back to work
now oh okay Greg cheated on you Ana with
Yolanda
whoops nope that's not what I wanted
okay what's this I miss the days where
opinions can only go for as far as you
go well that's a thing you know I'll be
right back what no whoa what is your
deal seriously where is your head at
whoa whoa that's not what I wanted yeah
what Yolanda just called me well all
right hang out I'll go deal with this
huh did anything happen while I was gone
I have no idea probably all right what
have you got there is a reasonable I
just want to know the full story that's
all yeah no I don't care about your
excuses you have crossed the line good
sir she is pissed a goose and you
brought her into this mess let's see I
had to be sure I had to be a hundred
percent sure my personal affairs has
nothing to do with you whoop-dee-doo you
cheated on Anna now that it's out in the
open
would you stop digging into my life and
get back on track only because you asked
so nicely just stop and use your head
for just one second have you ever
considered that what's-his-face form
spark is just [ __ ] you around come on
what do you really know about him let's
see he makes a lot of lewd jokes what
kind of nut case will joke about
something going someone going missing
it's like he lacks any kind of empathy
he did sidetrack the investigation so
pointing the finger at me was his idea
all along
and you said that I'm the one with
things to hide I won't be surprised if
he had some kind of a criminal record
he's just eccentric well I'm not taking
any chances with him look what I found
Oh spark related crimes Sora's
increasing number of felons use dating
apps to target victims well it doesn't
sound good
dating apps have been linked to more
than 500 crimes
several arrests seems like everyone's
just trying to and national sex felon
website NSFW huh okay alright then I see
[Music]
okay what do we got here who's on the
west okay first name let's try through
Greg Sommers no Greg Greg Sommers no
records found all right that's good
that's a good thing you don't need to do
that that's okay don't do that all right
okay yeah what's taking so long
hang on wait whoa have you cleared it
with a I'm stuck I'm stuck I don't
understand
put in the name age location how ours
that I need a location I just don't know
where hmm is he on Jabbar
oh okay all right then
Taylor you go to tail say Taylor mm-hmm
that would have been smart I didn't even
this Pringle
Springwood it's perfect it's the perfect
crime how would they report it okay
Springwood got it toto
Springwood look up Wow record no opening
gross lewdness and lascivious behavior
indecent exposure and public sexual
indecent I'd rather not rather not do
that okay if you got sloppy you gay
you're offline again okay all right oh I
got the dirt on Greg I spoke to Yolanda
how do you know what Yolanda you
wouldn't know I got the durka I got the
dirt on Greg I got the dirt on Greg from
you-know-who Yolanda's oh wait never
mind
no I gave her the name let's see he's a
lover not a fighter
hmm so Greg is not the violent type I
assume I guess my theory about Greg
making into disappear
someone someone far-fetched was this
someone walked by me on the sidewalk and
said hello freak that's very funny
hashtag relatable okay alright let's see
an [ __ ] but not a criminal
mmm-hmm speaking it's criminal you sure
Greg didn't let anything slide can you
source even be trusted
let's see you our side tracking us all
right Greg is keeping something about
Ana I can feel it
let's see you jealous of him no no way
maybe maybe probably yes a little yeah
of course I am I mean he is my
competition after all how can I compete
with an ex like you don't even know what
this is you sound ridiculous this isn't
about that who's about Ana being gone I
don't think this guy did anything about
it he's just an idiot apparently a
seconder but I really think that guy's a
nut job and he's hiding some dark stuff
let's see he is not the only one I got
I got nothing and you didn't find
anything did you if you have something
to say spill it
let's see you've been you've been a
naughty boy you've been naughty well
some girls would agree I can pull off
some sweet moves this is a voice message
damn you found the damn registry didn't
you I know it looks really bad a guy on
spark being a sex offender is as bad as
it gets but hear me out please
game over [ __ ] alright wait you have
see you have five seconds one okay I got
I'll make it quick let's see I want all
that nope I don't want the juicy details
just keep it short so total it was all a
misunderstanding
someone caught me with my pants down in
a public place
end of story I changed my mind
tell me more I don't want to go okay so
I was at a mall
like a huge glass of iced tea right
before I gotta pee real bad the bathroom
with clothes on the floor I was on in
the next one it was really far away
let's see and then but there was
something about the gross sexual
misconduct that's more then this lady
with her kid came through I was exposed
next thing you know lawyers were
involved and I was charged let's see
that was your only crime you got to
believe me I don't believe that your
only crime you technically call me a
criminal but I would never harm another
person come on you can trust me said
every guilty person ever I'm not I know
it sounds weird but this is not about me
now I have to follow so many strict
rules from the NSFW that I'm practically
branded do you know how hard it is to
find a job let's see sounds awful
oh yeah sounds awful I'm just keeping my
head low oh I meant that to be more
sarcastic than this guy's probably
taking it if I mess up it's straight to
jail for me I would never do anything
remotely illegal so let's just keep this
between you and me eh all right it's a
real conversation starter don't play
with me on this I'm serious well do
something
I'll indecently exposed myself or I
guess I'm done there what else we got
whoa [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I can't believe you
actually did it I just told you not to
tell anyone
wait I didn't do anything Ethan Greg he
added me on jabbers oh he's definitely
pissed how the hell did he find me let's
see I might have told him about you
maybe a few words hither and thither god
damnit oh [ __ ] it he added me on his
phone oh hey nice group chat
Tyler got you now you sex maniac
there's a little hello shut up reboot
guy I'm the one Hanna should be with you
stay out of this I don't think you guys
are focusing on the right priorities
here I think you guys should probably
Greg let's see it's about time you all
work this out get to chatting then we
can get down to business
how'd you get my number well chase the
Internet is a resourceful place
especially for finding pervs like you
Wow from cheating to stalking can
someone hand him the best boyfriend of
the Year award well I do my private eyes
none of your business I suppose maybe
you're the one who drove her away in the
first place how about I Drive my foot up
your dick hole that's a that's a good
one that way I'm gonna use that I'm
gonna use the hi how about I Drive my
foot up your dick hole line many times
all right both of you shut up you don't
know what you're talking about here I
think you guys are missing the point and
I is missing we are all on point until
shit-for-brains showed up book man and I
wanted to move on why can't you respect
that she would be better with literally
anyone else but you so mister I can't
keep it in my pants too somehow an
acceptable choice for her at least I
don't have a criminal record with a
little blue man needs BA okay guys have
fun are you gonna say something I'm not
done with you yet what the hell did you
do to Anna if you touch her I swear how
can I do anything if I haven't even met
her yet she mentioned that she me is
meeting someone from spark on her
notebook have you ever considered that
there are literally millions of other
lonely single men out there of course I
did and I'm starting with you that is
not working smart I just want her back
[Music]
let's see ah there is a smarter way to
do this guys we are wasting time here
this this group chat is real cool I'm so
glad that Greg picked out a specific
icon for this but y'all shut up we gotta
go find Anna finally we're agreeing on
something no I'm not agreeing with you
[ __ ] you are the one that accused me
and threw everyone off hey so my fault
that she
left you oh my god did your head in the
game
Taylor uh whatever I don't know who
depict shut up everybody we're all
partly to be blamed whoever I am I see I
didn't even tell you my name or whatever
if you're gonna be like this fine I can
prove that I didn't mean Ana you just
said you couldn't show me my spark
messages it's all there
I will prove that Ana and I never
planned to meet let's see he is telling
the truth me the guy who's perused Ana's
personal belongings I can confirm this
with my own two I ball z' can you be any
more insecure her found she cleared ed
about logged go
oh it's back develop I already looked if
I can access it I'll have all the proof
I need whoa whoa hey whoa I think you're
onto something if we do that we might be
able to know who she met on spark diam
that's true Sean finally we're all in
agreement we're best buds now in this
suite group chat
that's cute let's see you guys done
fighting till we get down to business
says the stranger no yes all right
what mmm nah until I see the messages oh
geez
whatever man get over it maybe we can
sell my collar office ask around for
help Oh get her some get someone to get
her computer or something what kind of
shitty idea is that we got [ __ ] hole
[ __ ] ideas that you [ __ ] brain I say I
will just walk right in and get it done
myself it's gonna be easy let's see
let's not walk right in let's let's call
her office let's just call excellent
maybe she has friends that we can trick
into getting under her computer we've
raced it enough time already
I'm not playing charades to get someone
think that important are you doubting me
yes yes I am
let's see should we discuss this or
should we act come on I'm done lit I've
done listening to you
I've
I'm just gonna walk in and get the job
done plain and simple that's too
reckless oh my god
you've children let's find him ordered
indirect weights call one of her work
friends I know her better oh she has no
work friends oh my god
and what makes you think you can use
your computer so easily I Gregg is
there's no [ __ ] way that Gregg's
idea is better just call someone and get
someone let's trick someone that's it
two to one favor and that's how
democracy works since we're all in
agreement feel like we're becoming in
sync fine be that way
but I get to be Lance Bass no that's
yeah that's no yes no you BJT is Lance
Bass Backstreet Boys this is the
important question that's gonna be on my
brain for ever okay anyway Joey Fatone
if she did end up meeting you
you won't hear the end of it oh I'm sure
oh no Greg no come on man
you made this cool group why did you
leave okay so that just happened that
was really fun that was nice sorry for
the outburst it's not meant for you I
just want to make things right and I
gotta do it on my own okay if we met
under other circumstances maybe we would
have got along I doubt it but there is a
possibility there I said it
what did you just say that you were
we're best buds now did you manage to
check her emails if you can read them
all that would be great let's see
there's a guy who is harassing her
harassment nailed it we can use this are
you up for some blackmail I'm thinking
what you're thinking Oh Taylor you and I
are on the same page after all use that
email against him tell him that you're
turning him in threaten him make him
feel bad I don't know all right fine
can do easy I asked him to do your
bidding
it's change for the harassment email
okay all right Oh
only you can think of something like
this something so deviously genius
Greiner I'll do anything okay all right
then well that's it works sorry sorry no
need to respond just want to try to call
Ana's phone see if it's working Beadon
trying to get it and I I finally did I
guess next is to find her yeah so yeah
bye
okay all right bye what is this I've
decided not to call Victor back you
remember him oh boy
[ __ ] okay the guy from the club yup I'm
thinking he's just not right for me
don't feel connection you know let's see
yeah I forget about him
am I too picky is there something wrong
with me I love you just the way you are
love you too we should totally get
together soon okay all right okay all
right Ashley I helped I did good I think
I don't know if I did good Merv you're
gonna love it at whoa yeesh greetings
Merv greetings Merv wherever you burn
though everyone's been looking for you I
need a favor
I need a favor
you never asked me for anything before
what gives I need you to get a phone
backup from my PC
using another employee's pcs against
company policy why can't you do it
yourself
let's see I am caught up with something
it's incognito that can't be right [ __ ]
you're not Anna aren't you [ __ ] I should
have known
okay we are done let's see uh I guess
you like being known as a pervert
Merve blackmail is that what's happening
you know I can get sued for sharing
company secrets right if you still want
access to Anna's computer I'm not doing
it let's see what if I post your emails
all over Jabbar mm-hmm what about that
god [ __ ] damnit fine you win well
that was easier than I thought
looks like I'm screwed either way I need
get a password reset for PC but HR will
text your phone to verify you have to
pretend to be Anna otherwise they will
never get me access I'm up bro I'm a pro
at pretending to be Anna you've done
this before geez just make it quick okay
all right and guy your password was but
I didn't see you in today is everything
okay let's see let's see I was out with
a client just now
I think I was out with a client yeah hmm
I didn't know you were assigned to
servicing today I must have missed
something before I reset your password
can I run something by you sir first
let's see anything you know the report
you handed to me last week I finally got
it let's see
and the results I got some good news and
bad news
it says here that you're making an
official sexual harassment report
against Merv let's see
yep that's the one that is the one I
brought this up with my manager and he
told me to tell you to seriously think
about this
company can't afford to get into a
scandal right now and send a glued
emails while technically is reportable
it's one of the smaller offense let's
see that's ridiculous
his words not mine hmm so we suggest you
drop the report while he will have a
talk with Merv Oh everything will be
fine put it all behind and he might
approve that study you'll leave you've
been meaning to get but if you want you
can still let the report go through
facing forcing mr. farraday's hand it's
just going to upset him let's see ah
justice is more important send that
report the [ __ ] if you insist
okay consider it done personally I think
you're doing the right thing
oops almost forgot I just reset your
password Thanks see ya at the barbecue
you okay all right then ha Merv get rekt
I guess I don't know if that's doesn't
okay got the reset and I'm in alright
still clear on your task do you know
what you're doing mr. secret agent man
yeah get the phone back upright give me
a second okay all right I'm waiting it's
starting down let me build it out gonna
take a while to complete and then just
explode all over my phone right probably
I don't understand what's going on but
you're not the only one who wants access
to this computer uh there's someone else
mmm that's confusing
well I'm waiting for the reset some dude
came by demanding to use Ana's computer
he look cost quite a scene and security
took him away I think his name was Greg
not to go see with you let's see uh I
might know him I know I might well
getting him in was not part of the deal
your friend is going to regret doing
that finally I told him not to finally
it's done whoa all right here we go
okay James wait James that was the icon
that was all kinds of kerfuffle okay all
right well that's this is the opposite
of restore
well that's but no that's not good
nothing is as it seems all right
alder good see have you found er now not
yeah I don't know what you're talking
about
no I have not getting closer
uh-huh let's see
oh wait I got it you need to hurry she
is running out of time oh no the
opposite of that she is running out of
time you need to hurry okay all right I
don't know why you're in such a rush mr.
silly pants c-can you help me please
it's just dumb desperate I don't know
why the times are all weird let's see
yes the answer is in spork I know I'm
kind of on it I'm almost there
you gotta give me life how do I know
it's why I've been trying to do it
before you interrupted me her survival
and many more depends on you she mad she
mad I'm not it it is not me find me find
it I still don't know who you are I
cannot remember time is short if you
fail
he will share my friend
I don't know why you're talking like
that that's weird
okay oh all right well that's a face you
know we use emojis nowadays okay that's
not good I don't like that I like that I
like that
oh yeah like that oh no don't like that
oh well you're dead okay I still don't
understand what this pictures all about
am i looking for something new something
Oh
nothing is as it seems apparently okay
yeah come on don't be so weird bloggers
time to go vlogger only three more vlogs
this entire email is in the subject line
and it's all in caps that's just rude
like internet rude god and my dumb
colleague won't stop texting me but not
oh god I cannot wait to leave there and
work with animals
yeah cuz animals don't treat me like
garbage still waiting on my vet school
application though hope I get it well
I'm sorry apparently you're not gonna
get the vet school thing and it's just
the long and the short of it there ain't
nothing to do spark weekly sparks okay
alright good stuff
wonderful jabber okay love is around the
corner chats what do we got ooh man some
juicy here I'm probably gonna need to
read this so I'm able to actually get
this thing : no no keep going back and
forth wait this is the same okay but
there's new stuff right here like we
talked about just get on spark I don't
know oh I will make your profile for you
alright got it come on it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be fun I'll take care of
everything okay I'm gonna make your
profiles so good that even you would
date yourself
and I think it's time to unleash the hey
my eyes are up here dress okay alright
haha you're not going back to Greg so
what's arm mmm-hmm you can come over to
my place and we can swipe but I don't
feel like going out hard heart I'm
excited to see Toby takes a later do you
give spark know I don't really if I want
to if I really want to I know I could
date but it feels like those apps are
just objectifying anyway this missing
people like an emperor at the Coliseum
except I guess they get no chance to
fight because you're just looking at
some stranger's selfies wondering if
that's really their dog or if his ex
took the photo oh yeah this is supposed
to be fun we're not looking for your
husband just like visual stimulus Blair
Blair
boy oh yeah oh baby yeah alright see you
later game answer me sorry sorry sorry
started almost there okay I was doing an
errand and it turned into longer thing
than I thought just stay put at the door
I'll be there soon hmm well that was
only that was just a few days ago huh
ten of August is boy hunting um shut up
there's this guy I don't wanna jinx it
huh what's he like I'll text you next
time okay I might meet him aw don't make
this a big deal hmm alright well this
was just a couple days ago so I must
have been something okay alright did you
get the backup let's see it happened
again it happened again the deal is to
help with the backup I don't care if it
works what's done is done I trust you're
gonna keep my chats with Anna a secret
let's see sorry creep you're done for
yeah I will yeah I will
thank God God thank you I swear she
won't hear from me again that is not a
compliment yeah alright well alright
well anyway okay got that
wait there's a new email [ __ ] yeah you
really [ __ ] up didn't you Greg I think
I'm in trouble yeah yeah I know I'm
aware Greg I'm aware I'm aware what were
you thinking and I told you sacrifices
must be made
the interest of the company I am now
certain you can only think for yourself
two choices come to my office except my
official warning letter and leave a
stain on your career or hand over your
resignation okay I'll take your official
warning letter guess that's fine with me
all right wait I got to check all this
stuff James James just the right amount
of awkward James works at fresh ideas
I've been called metrosexual but it's
not what you think I'm not attracted to
trains that is so goddamn funny oh my
god okay that was a lot of corrupted
[ __ ] okay hang on I got to pour
through this [ __ ] copywriter okay you
must be a smooth texture only when it
comes to seducing corporate clients you
still with them then oh this is gonna
take a bit so I'm gonna restore it all
and then I'm gonna get to it oh wow
that's handy it fixed all of it there
yeah that would have been a that would
have been a [ __ ] and a half okay so it
fix all of it meet me this weekend and
I'll show you smooth fine but you better
actually be useful I can think of a few
things we can use haha like what depends
on my move fun to fly now Saturday night
7:00 p.m. uptown you're lucky that's
good timing for me so yeah see you soon
be there in an hour I'm here where you
are I see you I see you okay well that's
where that ended okay all right see did
the blackmailing work out not you let's
talk - no not you Greg all right yeah I
know yeah yeah I heard I heard about it
you do feet idiot yeah [ __ ] I slipped up
how the heck I knows that someone else
will be at her computer wha ah you could
have asked me first why do I need
permission from you to do anything
Oh too late for that now okay this is
real bad the cops are involved now
let's see Merv made it real clear that
guy at Anna's desk what the hell is his
deal
looks like say he had something shoved
up his ass do me a favor don't get the
cops involved anymore
I cannot get another target on me I will
be arrested for sure let's see your
secret is safe with me good buddy if
something happens to me I'm dragging you
down well that threat is unnecessary I'm
gonna keep looking for Anna alone
you just stay quiet I didn't do fine
[ __ ] right did the blackmailing work
went perfectly perfectly without a hitch
couldn't even imagine it going any
better than that so what did you find in
the past spark messages just read all of
them to find out who did meet I got him
I met with James alder James huh sounds
handsome oh pretty normal I would
imagine the culprit might have a scarier
name what else he got he is unnaturally
good at guessing Anna's past
sounds like stalker material to me
wonder if there's any way to confirm
this mm-hmm
let's see he met keeping it Cassie
before Anna that's in no way what a
playa
she's like a jabber sulabha I hope she's
all right she looks half to give active
on jabber if we can somehow talk to her
maybe she can share what she knows about
him he works at a design firm called
fresh ideas with a pH that's a pretty
cheesy name yeah I agree
even for my taste maybe there's
something someone there that can tell us
what's up with him
looks like we got enough to start with
its James fellow it's close I can feel
it okay yeah me too I'm not gonna go
with the whole assuming she's alive or
out because all nerves ghost keeps
talking to me
you got the most resources to figure out
who this James person is I think you
need to track this Cassie person down
and call his work place dig a little
more about him okay all right I'll try
Cassie first I like going on
Jabar it's my favorite plus I love those
do both I'll leave it up to you okay
right then okay but in time I'll give a
spark call maybe they have something on
this James person okay whatever you say
buddy well if you say bad in ski yeah I
got to go to fresh ideas okay
my email position Adam oh hang on one
second hello can you hear me
this is detective Marilla from the
police department again one of your
colleagues reported that someone is
attempting an unauthorized access to
your work computer to retrieve some
sensitive information this is a case of
corporate espionage and we have reason
to believe that a man named Greg Sommers
is behind it I'm informing you that your
personal data has been compromised and
that Greg is now wanted for questioning
if you have any information on his
whereabouts please contact me on this
number thank you and good day okay all
righty then well that is definitely a
thing anyway and at sea mail no I need
to go for this and a junior executive a
Faraday said junior executive is
bringing Ana at Sea mail dot web that's
email dot web position junior executive
okay so the position your no wait wait
shut up shut up over there wait wait
your position workset but what are you
what are you a copywriter a copywriter
wait a copywriter that's right that's
right that's right copywriter ana next
Ana
that's email web and copywriter ah okay
before we commence the interview it is
our policy to bouquet preliminary chat
all right I'll get there soon all right
Masen Mike something to think about
all right where is where is keeping it
coochi keeping it casual keeping it
could keep it to kasi there's keeping it
I see the fan a man will be published in
an article only the best gets picked
let's see uh Cassie I need to talk to
you about James all nur please please
contact me keep an eye on my upcoming
post find the hidden phone number if you
figured that out just call me for your
AMA with me it's 9:00 in the morning
9:00 it's 9:00 the morning to 3 9 to 3 9
to 3 8 9 - 3 8 1 9 - 3 8 1 9 - 3 8 1 4 9
- 3 8 1 4 0 9 - 3 8 4 1 0 9 - 3 8 1 4 0
that was it oh I cannot see why are you
in my book
hiya this is keeping it Cassie
congratulations you figured out the
secret number very hard yeah you know
you asked me one question for my
upcoming am a threat so please be
patient as I will contact you on my next
availability will be texting you soon
whatever you say keeping it gassy Oh got
your number yo yo yo yo
its first come first serve so let me
finish up with the earlier winners I
will get back to you once I'm done can't
wait okay alright well that's good
let me get back to my email I guess
while I'm waiting for that start the
interview oh [ __ ] hey you're up it's
your turn - AMAO [ __ ] remember you only
get one question let's see I will keep
it to one awesome possum ask away
let's see how well
you know James ulnar say what him how
the hell do you know about him
let's see he is a person of interest you
want dirt on him or something why go
through me don't you have normal
questions to ask like oh boy that's
gonna be vapid what do I think of
climate change little boy or the state
of social media shaping consumerism oh
boy you know normal questions yeah those
are normal questions the a stands for
anything yeah got him got him got him if
that's what you really want to know only
two conditions first boy tell me why do
you need info on him let's see he's a
key witness in a disappearance sweet
Jameis I knew something was up
oh boy oh god I could have been
kidnapped look I'm not sure what you
heard but this sounds seriously F job if
it's gonna help someone else I will tell
you everything but this is between us
my second condition is that we keep this
between us okay Wow okay all right okay
all right sure sure sure
okay sure it's a deal okay let me start
from the top here we go I'm ready I keep
my online persona keeping you casee him
I realized separately my real name is
Cassandra keeping the Cassie has always
been a single but I'm not I've had a
longtime boyfriend but I was dumped so I
went on spark and chatted with a few
guys to get over it
that's when I met James he was so dreamy
let's see did he act weird in a good way
of good kind of weird nothing at the
beginning actually started out fine he
was a real charmer seems to tell me all
the right things after coming off a
shitty relationship I was at a low place
he gave me some perspective and plenty
of good advice then he started to get
more things right about me let's see
sounds creepy to me that is nothing
wait till you hear this I'm all ears he
starts to text me exactly when I
finished my work I don't have a regular
schedule they change over weekdays even
but he somehow manages to text me at
exactly the right time there was a photo
shoot that ended at 2:00 a.m. he texted
me the moment the photographer called
roots in a wrap does he ever sleep okay
that is weird
man is exceptionally weird here's the
final straw he knew about the break-up I
worked my ass off to keep my
relationship a secret for the sake of
keeping it Cassie and somehow James knew
I confronted him and he told me he
guessed it look oh boy that's the last
time I heard from him I think those
chica so did your online persona drive
your boyfriend away how the hell do you
know about this I just took a guess
guessing exactly when I wake up and when
I finish work that has just plain creepy
finding out about my jabber in my friend
that is pure sorcery no one else knows
about this who the hell are you I'm a
methods to uncomfortable we are gone
okay yeah that is weird all right let's
see that is all I need to know okay are
we done sure that's it that's all I'm
saying just thinking about it makes my
hair stand all right
your story is gonna save lives you know
I read somewhere that psycho tracks past
try their best to fit in
I feel James is kind of like that hope
you got what you need there's something
off about him oh yeah yeah I agree I
agree all right oh if they have
something on the James person Oh what
Anna oh can we talk of course of course
you remember when I told you to make a
spark profile let's see yeah you made
one for me I know about it
it made me realize something it was a
defense mechanism for something
something that I can't hide anymore
oh boy ever feel like you could lie to
yourself so much you end up lying to
others you're not alone to feel that way
might be different in my case though
here's the thing and I you're the only
bestie I ever had I feel like I could
tell you anything and trust you with
anything okay all right whoa Oh Ashley
see I thought having BFFs supposed to
feel like this but I think I'm confusing
it with syndrome else
let's see Ashley just tell me I think I
think there's a reason why I could never
get along with guys tell me I won't
judge and it's the same reason why I
hated seeing you go out with Greg or
anyone else
uh-huh I'm just gonna cut to the chase
okay I have feelings for you okay there
I said it you don't have first bond you
can ignore this if you want to pretend
it never happened it's the fourth class
talking so don't listen to it let's see
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna ignore this one
we're just gonna ignore it and pretend
it never happened cuz oh boy
okay all right what if what do I do I
fit this is a moral dilemma do I spill
the beans about why is it so important
that Ana doesn't know well IRA why is it
so important that Ashley doesn't know
that Ana is missing why do i why would I
need to keep that illusion up I'm so
deep in the nest of Lies that I don't
know the way out did someone give me a
truth machete so I can cut my way
through the ligh jungle I don't know
what to do I don't know what to do
alright I'll just leave that there
alright so yeah anyway okay I'm gonna
take my selfie game up and it's really
nice that's clever see okay here we go
no wait what about the interview wasn't
in this thing see the conversation will
be recorded for internal use okay you're
offline I tracked down Cassie oh that
Jabbar hobby did she kiss and tell
let's see he can predict her real her
every move so he is either some
next-level stalker or there's something
didn't look to him that we don't really
know never mind
we know James is maximum creep material
creepy enough to kidnap Anna perhaps
have you called his workplace yet a
second opinion from a professional would
be great
okay alright haven't done that yet but
you know what it looks like it's not
gonna let me get out of this alright
sorry I can't keep this up anymore yeah
I'm gonna come out and say this is yeah
this is just bad so I can't keep this up
anymore huh what's wrong see I am the
not Anna I'm saying it what's up with
you
you know you've been acting really weird
recently and if that's really you call
me please well yep well I probably
didn't do the right thing but you know
what are you talking I can barely hear
you I'll explain everything later you
need to explain it now with Al's Anna
she is missing since when well well
about that it's right
after I told you about it Yolanda isn't
it I knew something was wrong
is Greg involved you lied to me let's
see I wasn't trying to hi why absolutely
was that line [ __ ]
we're done talking I'm calling the cops
well she didn't need to know I guess so
that is important all right
you vlog available oh well that's handy
good timing yes I figure I deserve to be
happy and forget about everything else
mm-hmm
there's no point wasting time so here I
go there you go okay okay okay all right
good all right good job okay now we can
talk
apparently howdy there howdy there is
this Anna let's see yes this is me Anna
this is me neato
oh man I'm Phil from fresh ideas or Phil
fresh you some of my buds call me get it
feel fresh oh boy we're off to a bad
start this is just an informal chat so
just loosen up and save it for the big
interview later hey so you ready
let's see yep
can I ask the questions instead not out
this works bud you can ask the questions
a little later okey-dokey okay got it
all right I'm ready Coolio
god I hate you I hate you already if I
use for now what do you see yourself
doing
let's see made an impact on your
company's bottom line get to the point
where I can tell people to develop the
skills to manage other people sure all
right let's do that one gun in for the
manager eh well we are a tiny firm
anything can happen in five years next
question
why should I are you oh god I have
learned stuff which might bring unique
value because hello this is detective
Murillo from the police department we
have strong evidence to suggest that you
are holding on to a missing persons
phone we also have reason to believe
that you are working with an accomplice
named Greg summers conspiring to keep
Anna's disappearance a secret this is an
obstruction of justice and I'm afraid I
will have to bring you and Greg in for
questioning
please a woman's life is at stake here
we are reasonable if you can assist us
with the investigation there will be no
charges call me back if you change your
mind okay I'm not gonna do that okay why
sure how are you I'm busy with an
interview mr. cop man
I can't possibly help you out I'm trying
to get a job do you know the economy is
like now shut up go to hell
also I hope Anna's fine that's just an
aside though all right I got other
talents besides Ratan here hey you
people with multiple talents are always
welcome here
how flexible are you we'd like to hear
more if you get shortlisted that last
question why do you want to work here Oh
ha ha James alder spoke highly of you
guys do you know him James
Oh haven't heard that name in a while
sorry bud why are you asking this let's
see so I won't repeat his mistakes and
he's made a great many missed a case
that's the kind of forward thinking
we're looking for it's a shame really
we had to let him go because of his
unprofessional behavior and see ah
is there a misunderstanding I really am
not sure to be frank I'm not liberty to
discuss any personal matters all I can
say socially he was one of our best he
gets along with people well and
generally likeable but that kind of
changed what do you mean did your
company change him he broke off with his
girlfriend
of course he was upset but he is still
himself until he got spark since then
he's been showing up late
he grew distant then one day he just
vanished
no he'd okey then how he went into the
bathroom for quite some time
understandable then I heard a strange
noise coming from it I even recorded
uh-oh I shouldn't listen to this yeah
thanks for sending me that very personal
stuff even though you can't talk about
it I went in there and checking no one
was there and the last time anyone saw
him in person let's see did you contact
him since Oh
we tried since then he never showed up
for work no phone calls no emails
nothing
so we terminated him plus our big
project coming up we don't really need
it right now
huh that is weird that's weird
what is weirder is that after he
disappeared we found his phone on his
desk
we tried checking it but I think it was
broken because it kept glitching out
someone say they still see him on jabber
some female friends even saw him on
spark whatever happened to that kid I
think he needs help professional help
God those noises are too realistic topic
yeah whoa sorry went off on a tangent
there thanks for the interview we'll
call you if you get the position
all right calls workplace
fresh ideas isn't it what have you got
for me Oh me every Wednesday is it Oh
hashtag relatable okay anyway James lost
his mind James ones missing as well mmm
no way this kind of confirms what I
found as well calling fresh ideas is a
great plan I think we got some great
leads okay you showed me yours
now let me show you my nope don't want
this I found something about James to
don't show me your dick okay what do we
got educate that self freedom to our
turnit of facts power through different
truths what the fake mass media do not
want you to see about the recent
appearances in dating apps whoa
account suspended my account got
suspended Oh
local news coverage what boy oh wait
that I already saw that so much trains
going on with spark okay all right
pictured how far to this story go okay
first of all crimes is not represented
Bubba - Bubba - Oh missing hmm I see the
yellow line labeled missing and no one
seems to bother mentioning this sure
it's only a small number so they just
lump it in with the rest of the crimes
lazy pigs Tracey P missing okay Simon be
missing okay
Amy T missing James a missing girl guy
girl guy and so on they all seemed to be
bookworms of sorts either studying or
working in related jobs they all broke
up recently with their girlfriend
boyfriends and are looking for love
except James but I'm willing to put
money that he did to trust no one there
was only us against them don't trust the
water in your pipes doubt your iris
you're talking about iris the the the
the company I think you are okay dear
Anna you've logged into your account
from unknown for security reasons we
have logged you out from all of the
devices to prevent further unauthorized
access well that's not that's not
suspended that's just logged out okay
let's see I already read it I read it oh
yeah I'm very readable I know what I'm
doing you can read it at your own time I
already did but I will keep this quick
TLDR told err
James vanished a couple months ago I
already know this met someone from spark
just like oh there's more okay
combine this with what you've found out
I think there's something bigger at work
here okay I
to record this so we are on the same
page so commencing epic monologue Anna
went missing the same way as James
they were both last seen going on a date
with someone on spark Anna and James
still had activity on jabber but no one
has physically seen them it's the same
pattern
james is still nowhere to be found
I hope Anna doesn't share the same fate
what where are you
ah you're right you are right I think
you're right probably anyway there are
too many similarities between Anna and
James for it to be a coincidence
whatever that's happening right now is
spooky Oh F there's an imposter going
around making people disappear and I
think he/she is assuming the identity of
James we gotta find him and I think I
know how C
why don't I have a say come on you've
been jabbering on forever I need to do
you did good so far
well let me figure this one out save and
get the girl am i right okay didn't mean
to sound weird but you get my drift
just give me some time I will let you
know right okay do I have another vlog
oh I'm in dead ends everywhere it's like
she vanished from the face of the earth
let's see let's see oh there's a new
vlog I am getting closer we are getting
closer in the group chat that you made
Greg if you would just join it again
this is not a [ __ ] competition I
can't get anything done with the cops
breathing down my neck I can't be caught
the way things are now
they will think I'm the reason Anna's
missing have they contacted you Ashley
ratted on you yeah sorry I had to tell
her oh my f G how did she know you told
her didn't you yep I mean why why do you
expect me to do she was confessing love
I'm not gonna keep that up I can't
confess love imma on the hollow husk of
a man I don't have anything in my heart
you need to do me a favor you can't I'll
let them know about me let's see
what is the worst that would happen what
is the worst thing okay alright well
you're gonna tell me in person okay pal
friend you know I have nothing to do
with Anna disappearing right you know
what they do to guys like me in jail
well I sure as hell don't want to find
out look if anyone asks you gotta back
me up dude Greg you are you are
absolutely hilarious
this [ __ ] socks going to jail is not
an option for me I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here
[ __ ] Anna whoa [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm
leaving this to you okay alright well
see you Greg see ya I guess what a dick
hole alright then I think I got
something you Bugs Bunny fan what does
that have to do anything then this is
relevant because Taylor you're the only
one left here and I need your help I'm
getting there
there are plenty of episodes where he
will dress up like a girl - Laura's
enemies into trap classic oh I see where
this is going but I don't like it you
thinking what I'm thinking I don't want
to think what you're thinking I don't
even want to know how your brain works
we need to lure this creep out just like
Bugs Bunny ah let's catfish him let's do
it I'm ready yes yes what if we catch
this imposter aka James in the act if
this is some creep luring victims on
spark we should beat him at his own game
yeah I don't think that's a good idea
when they seem to have some ethereal
powers with which to affect my phone we
can do the same wait where the guy's
pretend to be children online to catch
pedos we can do the same by we you mean
me right boy
yeah of course I have to do that you do
have a phone and stuff I can give it a
shot - yeah all right
sure let's see what happened use an to
spark account netted in a new new
profile try to match with James set up a
meeting okay then bust him from there
I'm gonna bust him alright oh I'm gonna
bust them all over the place you ain't
gonna know how hard I'm sexual isn't it
okay how do I do that so if there's
anything I learned from using spark and
watching TV and read almost all dating
advice out there
you got to be the person's type to get a
better match type obli who they like huh
okay all right right everyone has their
own tastes and types all the people who
disappeared while using spark shared
something in common just make sure the
profile you make contains tags that are
similar to them Oh baby I'm gonna be all
over those tags
oh I'm I'll be all over those tags how
do I think I can make a guess I got this
just let me do this you're thinking what
I'm thinking the article I sent you is
full of clues you even spoke to Cassie
all the missing people Anacostia stir
something in common you just gonna find
out what that is and make profile with
the correct tags if I can do it you can
do it let's see just be as smooth as
your charming he's a little work you
know I'll remember that yeah you better
by the way you might need these ah why
do you why why do you have glues mm-hmm
why do you have those there's some pics
you can use for the profile as long as
you don't use the Anna's pics it's fine
so you just have three women's photos
lying around
you mean you no I do not I don't I
really don't you don't have friends and
sharing pictures of pretty girls with
you nope you know I really don't know no
that's just creepy that's I just know
mm-hmm okay this looks bad again yes
yeah it does we can debate about this
later we are so close go to Anna spark
profile and start creating to catch the
criminal you got to be the victim make
sure your profile is similar to theirs
remember the secret is in the tags
alrighty then
now let's look at this vlog why is this
in the shower
[Music]
you all right
you okay
okay um I don't know these words mean
okey-dokey all right yep don't know what
that meant either well let's get into it
let's do this I'm gonna we're gonna do
this okay let's go with you okie dokie
and my name is from my age is 24 my work
studies are in tag line is I'm so
[ __ ] lonely there we go all right
just just broke up with my douche bag
boyfriend [ __ ] wait wait a minute
wait I just remembered something
wait I just remembered something wait I
just remembered something
it said the pattern was
boy-girl-boy-girl so this is I I can't
have that no I need to be ah I don't ah
that's right that's right it was boy
girl boy girl so I got to be Greg my
name is sprung 24 YouTube's so [ __ ]
lonely just broke up with my my my [ __ ]
ex-girlfriend I'm just a lonely boy who
who who needs to move on from my
previous shitty relationship and get
some dick
nope not a write get some poop in my
face I'm sorry just really direct about
my fetishes anyway or anyone anyway
anyone will do
okay moving on personal growth
growling there we go oh hell yeah yep
yep yep yep yep yep yep yep yep yep well
that didn't work
hmm anybody anybody want a date sprung
fair all right fine I'll use the damn
picture let's try this one
Oh 99 matches well that's a lotta it's
too late for me okie I'm no longer of
this world she still could be served do
not trust this words nothing is what it
seems
who's that oh [ __ ] all righty then
oh you know ki then that sucks okay
[Applause]
hello hi he's anyone there please answer
me yes I don't know where I am
help let's see you're not and what the
heck happened I don't know the last
thing I remember I was going out I met
James [ __ ] I remember he was standing on
the roof is he okay let's see that's not
important now he died didn't he oh god
it's my fault I saw him then I blacked
out you got to get me out of here I
think I was drugged
where are you now a warehouse a building
I don't know it's dark I can't tell I'm
really scared
I've been trying to reach out thank God
I found James's phone James's phone was
found by someone else oh it must be
someone else's phone then it I don't
know that is not important I think I can
help myself now I will get out and get
help thanks for not giving up on me I
should go let's see I'm not letting this
go he told you didn't he
let's see who are you really reveal
yourself demon how persisted that's me
Morgan boy I am her as she is man win
then you are not gotta pay if it as may
wish to see them so a worthy Pretender
my perversion fails to deceive you
dog barking to my mess huh mask all
right
see thank you thank you thank you thank
you I'm very clever my commendation is
not a sign of victory
okay the original and the copy are not
one AHA momentarily as she is no you
rejected all of my warnings do you crave
the truth so badly
yes flying determination to save this
female has led you to me aha tender
that's me I am a tender of pre let's see
you've got you've got some splaining to
do come on down and the simulacra eye on
your glass screens aha your black nurse
is a reflection of your reality aha and
that reality right alrighty you are
you're in the phone
I am the new order grin existence
perfected that sounds about right and
society very English and destined for
ascension where to that hyperreal
existence I like hyper-real okay
no I just want to save Anna so I want I
guess you're a finite perception will be
your own thing
okay the material society is fading or
taking its place cool a reality
we're only perfect symbols of humanity
exists murder their online personas aha
there's Samuel a crows creepy huh huh
okay alright what did she do wrong
you're taking this too seriously why
don't you relax a little bit come on
simulacra characteristic with me to take
matters too seriously
okay gonna miss a world I suppose that
needs to be eradicated a weak individual
that only laments a strong individual
would simulate a better one ah in the
online world all right it's art like
Second Life
not everything is about online personas
humans interact with their Senor
occurrence
nor must exclusively detached from the
material world righty holding labor Oh
picking food huh choosing habitants yep
si si thinking mates leaving the screens
hmm is that not everything I mean you
still gotta go out into the real world
and eat that food and seek those mates
and blink that but doink
I mean you've kind of got to work out
and what's your point I'm getting real
bored here uh-huh into obscurity right
yeah all kind of precious space I
simulate them yeah okay how strong we
darted other worms for removal delete
the original source from the material
rule
okay so do you suck them into their
phones I delete you mean kill right just
so we're on the same page Anna like
James before ah cease to exist
righty-ho next worm favor next one to be
cold
will not delay my simulation of him any
longer not Taylor that creepy weirdo let
it go I guess you should see that's maze
of the weakness yeah okay for the next
[Music]
Oh Anna told me she's gonna be here
this is really weird we might not even
be here it might be a trap
so
if it turns out to be a bunch of
kidnappers or something tell the world
at least I tried
uh-huh yeah well all right then let's
see let's see no that's not a no no
don't do it no stop Oh we were looking
for Ana this whole time and we found her
why are you being a buzzkill she even
sent me pictures to prove it
let's see did she say where she was all
along well duh you had her phone also
she said someone else I think she means
you was hogging her spark account when
she finally remembered her password she
logged back in please don't know Taylor
not only ready to brag but I have a
green belt in karate I can take care of
myself maybe we jumped into conclusions
if it really is Ana
we'll find out there and then I have to
go to her don't go yet
go then don't blame me don't blame
that's what I'd say go then don't blame
him if things go bad for an [ __ ]
again with this how about no I'm sick of
you treating me like some sort of
sidekick I've played a huge part in
getting you this far and all you can do
is push me aside time and time again
let's see oh stop your whining oh it's
coming to this are we about to duke it
out huh I got fists oh [ __ ] it I'm ready
to use them buddy just because you have
her phone doesn't mean you have the
right to boss me around to be a jerk a
little bit of respect would go far you
know how do I know you're telling me the
truth you tried to do me into thinking
that you were Anna for all I know that's
not the only thing you lied about do you
even care about Anna you didn't share
her emails with me whatever there's
something that you've missed were you
just trying to add thing for me
oh god calm down will you I just don't
care about this
no you still see me as a criminal don't
you despite all my efforts of finding or
you accused me of having something to do
with her disappearance is that all am do
you
a criminal I think you've got some
unresolved trust issues to look into
after pouring my heart out about the
truth by my sexual assault charges you
never believe me not one bit
I'm starting to think that maybe I was
better off on my own let's see I
seriously doubt that that's it I'm done
with you I'm done with you if that's how
I'm being treated then I might as well
get out of your way I'll just say man to
myself you'll see Oh fine see then god
I'll be in this amazing group chat by
myself a week uh-huh
pointless yeah I beware of that kind of
ghetto lately he's just being emotional
an emotional jerk who could have taken
me yeah but I didn't feel like it yeah
why no of crisis hmm he is going to
follow his own will that's too bad for
him then let's see what do you plan to
do with him
aha I sing for more words to be arranged
right okay eventually after his
usefulness
okay well simulacrum will become a card
reality right all right then
okay they don't deserve to die youth is
decay and bone there's simulacra are
eternal that's not good
that's good Sony's existence is
approaching its end us what can you do
against an unstoppable force and your
reality will become well I am an
unmovable douchebag and I don't think
you're unstoppable alright alright then
Oh No
[Music]
Hey did I get the ah man did I get the
worst ending possible whoo ah you and
82% of players did not turn Taylor into
him what wait a minute what what you and
62% of players choose not to hurt
Ashley's feelings you and 41% of players
help Greg escape the police you and 36%
of players reported Merve sexual
harassment it's too low that sucks you
and 36 players did not get Taylor to
trust you you and 82% of players did not
turn Taylor into a murderer all right
okay I guess sure we're gonna go with
that
Taylor's lack the trust and you made him
take matters into his own hands which
caused the demise of himself and Anna is
that what you intended simulacra as many
Easter eggs and multiple endings play
again and try for a different outcome
well did you enjoy the experience yeah
sure yeah okay I did give us a rating
leave a review nah I never do that all
right next
whoo well that is simulacra now a lot of
you may be going like Oh mark you didn't
get the good ending or could you do it
and a die well to be perfectly honest
how would you even have known going into
it the first time that Taylor was the
one to trust Greg was not in all honesty
where's the line nev and determine which
one is which so I played it the way I
wanted to play it I got that ending I
thought it was a really good game news
it was definitely in the same vein as
Sarah's missing and definitely along
those same lines just in a bigger and
better way but that is the end and
that's all for sin Elantra so
unfortunately we're all just digital
copies of ourselves idealized in a
digital
form and maybe that's the way that life
is just supposed to be maybe we should
all just roll over and accept it because
there's nothing that we can do to change
our faiths after all and who's to say
that it's not better for us just to wear
the masks that are our digital personas
and live out our lives as those maybe
that is for the best
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know you thought down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye